offshore rigs necessary to extract oil
hard to get to and dangerous
so siemens has developed a 3d game to
train workers before they arrive
oil derricks are often far away they're
remote they're in cold seas i'm gonna go
visit one but virtually
my task is simple enough find a leaky
pump turn the valve and shut it off but
my instructor threw me a surprise then
i'm going to turn my head oh i see the
fire i see a valve it's leaking
can't go over there a man is down the
question is do i save him or do i stop
the process and then save more lives oh
that's too hot
at first i'm slow and awkward but then i
get the hang of it that's by design yeah
it's actually made
with the idea to be a game-like so the
users don't have to be the experts in
some 3d application they can use it
as a
just a simple game product offerings
like this one called comos are an
example of siemens europe's largest
engineering company trying to go digital
the company already employs some 17 000
software engineers more than sap
and after i put out the fire i try to
run and then jump off a soon to be
exploding rig my avatar is quite poised
and doesn't know just how cold north sea
waters can be